the last time Sammy the bull Gravano did
an exclusive interview was with Diane
Sawyer on primetime TV back on April 16
1997 a lot has changed since 1997 we now
have the Internet we now have social
media we now have smartphones we now
everybody having a camera a lot to
change in America as Sammy the bull
Gravano changed cont Donna put the
[ __ ] gloves on with me I'll show you
how scared I am of you and you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] Paul God kills and John
Gotti became the boss but that's not the
story I was basically the guy who played
there I rigged the trials I threatened
people I [ __ ] blind people this is all
fact and he turns on me so how many of
them 19 did you pull the trigger love
you want to talk about the worst of me
to put the 19 murders do I want to talk
how I feel with that how I felt maybe on
some of those murders told me the [ __ ]
apart this is monster to the core this
is true cause in Austin
[Music]
you